across the western hemisphere millions
are on the move fleeing poverty crime
repression and climate change
this was the focus of the final day of
the summit of the americas with this
declaration we're transforming our
approach to managing migration in the
americas
each of us each of us is signing up to
commitments that recognizes the
challenges we all share
the los angeles declaration on migration
includes burden sharing with countries
in central and south america agreeing to
streamline the path for migrants to
resettle the u.s is putting up more than
300 million dollars to finance the
effort
countries have agreed to absorb higher
numbers of refugees and temporary
workers for example mexico will
integrate twenty thousand refugees into
its workforce the u.s will resettle
twenty thousand refugees next year a
small number given the enormity of the
problem migration is a humanitarian
crisis and a political problem for
president joe biden but it's not only
the u.s that is grappling with the
surging human tide in colombia
in colombia we have received 1.8 million
venezuelan migrants brothers and sisters
that have fled the worst oppression and
we have received them without being a
rich country the u.s pledged to improve
its efficiency and fairness in
processing people arriving at its
borders and will lead a law enforcement
effort targeting human trafficking gangs
if you prey on desperate and vulnerable
migrants for profit
we are coming for you
we are coming after you
no one expects these measures to stop
migration the reasons are many the
causes are deep and the pressures are
strong
security my country currently is subject
to great insecurity there are armed
groups that are stealing raping killing
and kidnapping be it haitians or foreign
citizens by these criminal activities
they have prevented free circulation of
people and goods in the country the
declaration is unlikely to satisfy
everyone despite the smiles and the
handshakes relations in the americas are
acrimonious
but it is a step forward and given the
controversies disagreements and no-shows
that have marked this summit it is
perhaps more than many may have hoped
for rob reynolds al jazeera los angeles